welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Loki
season 2 episode 6 the season finale and
perhaps series finale episode titled
glorious purpose which yes was the title
of the first episode of the series
because we have come full circle with a
brilliant somber finale that finally
fulfills Loki's purpose this was one of
the most beautifully written and
designed stories to ever come out of
Marvel Studios and I am going to break
it down piece by piece to illuminate the
hidden meaning the details you missed
some questions you might still have have
and to celebrate and appreciate this
glorious series Breaking Down each
episode of Loki has been so rewarding
for me and I just really appreciate you
guys sticking with me week after week
thank you also I am super excited for
new rockstars live show this Thursday
November 16th at brain dead Studios and
Los Angeles you got to be there since my
loky theories in Mesto and wav Vision
got debunked this week new rockstars is
forcing me to go on a public apology
tour I'm not kidding ticket info in the
description and yes I am wearing our Obi
inspired we're all going to die shirt
which is the best way to support us here
at new rockstars you can get it at nerd.
shop okay in the previously on Section
the first clip we open with is this I am
Loki of asard and I am burdened with
glorious purpose this is the first time
we heard Loki say these words in the MCU
and man look at this guy just look at
how far we have come as this episode
forms a book in for the series The
Opening Marvel Studios title card
reverses
and I love the new impact we get from
this reversed MCU imagery like the
chala's impact shock wave condenses into
him the Avengers Glide backward through
the quantum tunnels reversing the Time
Heist of endgame it's like all of MCU
history is capable of being reversed and
yes we hear at new rockstars did reverse
this back to the normal Direction so
that we could try to listen for any
Paul's Dead audio secrets that they
might have snuck in there roll it but
let go is here oh my God I'm just
kidding I just I just did that it really
is just the music reverse and I added
the misto stuff for we begin in the glow
of the Sacred timeline seen from an
angle we've never seen before now
composer Natalie Hol includes this
chanting
choir I think this might be the Norse
poetic Eda Loca that Natalie Hol tweeted
about in recent weeks which is an epic
poem in which Loki curses the other gods
for bringing about the Ragnarok
apocalypse with their vices Loki in this
episode will avert Ragnarok for his
friend by creating an eer worlds tree of
his own we see the words for all time
always etched on the outside of the door
and we Glide in through the windows to
find ourselves back at the events at the
end of episode 4 it's har to be
brave Loki has time slipped back into
his younger self now this is significant
because every other time Loki has time
slipped his body has been detached and
he sees a past version of himself set on
its own destined life path like he's
just kind of a witness to his own
history but here this time Loki Time
Slips his Consciousness back into his
own body it's Consciousness displacement
a distinct type of time travel that I've
identified in the past it's the kind
that Wolverine goes through in X-Men
Days of Future Past and what Desmond
goes through in lost this means that
Loki is now in control of his Destiny or
so we think Loki says they need to get
timely out of there but Victor has
already suited up so Loki for this Loop
just kind of has to observe and judge
how best to alter the next Loop this
time we see Victor run out from the
side
and now the Strand just kind of float
back through the door and I love that
that big vent just kind of goes slack to
let us know that he's dead Loki asks OB
what could we have done differently we
took too
[Music]
long yes this needle drop is a fifth of
Beethoven Walter Murphy's 1976 disco
arrangement of Beethoven's Fifth
Symphony famous from the SAT Night Fever
soundtrack Beethoven's Fifth is also
known as the Fate Symphony its opening
notes historically considered to be fate
knocking at the door this comes from
Beethoven's secretary Anton Schindler
who wrote after Beethoven's death the
composer himself provided to these deps
when one day in this author's presence
he pointed to the beginning of the first
movement and expressed in these words
the fundamental idea of his work thus
fate knocks at the door and so this next
sequence shows Loki struggling to fight
that faded knock at the door that
delivers helping after helping of
spaghetti since Natalie Hol obviously
loves disco from her episode 2 1977
disco rendition of the series theme we
just get to watch John the Major's die
over and over to Walter Murphy's Swanky
disco beat and I love how the editing
makes it seem like it is Loki himself
commanding the DJ to kick up the tempo
fost okay okay no time to argue so in
Loop two Loki takes over for OB to
breathe Victor and hurries him down the
steps now Victor passes through the
briefest purple light even this journey
we learn from he remains later was paved
by the purple guy loop three Loki tries
to go even faster and discovers that
there's a microphone that he can use to
direct Victor but Victor dies again now
Loki says no faster it's it over earlier
so Loop 4 Loki goes back to the War Room
a few minutes earlier in episode 4's
timeline this would be a scene that we
didn't actually see in the episode
shortly before we cut back to Victor
showing raana Brad and Miss minutes how
the throughput multiplier worked when
Brad was already sitting on the table
but here Victor says M Rona after what
happened in my Miss minutes I think he
was about to call out Miss minutes for
trying to make a move on him back in the
workshop Loki tells Miss BS I know right
now you're hurt and you're angry but we
need your help in finishing the through
pit multiplier f
yeah that confused little blink sound
effect it's just so great Loki watches
Victor go again to his death and the
word skin is still traced in the Dust by
Mobius from episode 1 Loop five this
time he has Sylvie instead of Casey
dragging Victor back into the loom room
maybe Sylvie made faster work of Ren
Slayer and Brad Loop six we see the loom
explode and Loki just pounds on the door
Loop seven Victor spaghetti fies because
he opened the door before he put his
helmet on or picked up the multiplier
Loop eight same deal there's no headgear
he's not holding the multiplier and then
Loops 9 through 11 we see three deaths
two of them with no helmet one with so
Loop 12 Victor actually makes it out a
few steps but then falls to his knees
and look at this death the skin peels
off of his skull and jawbone from the
bottom up and it looks like the guy just
opened the Arc of the Covenant so the
next Loop Loki goes all the way back to
when Victor was first introduced to OB
in the RNA Department Loki jumps
straight to that model of the Loom that
OB had made this model is not finished
okay there's only one coat of paint on
this only one coat of paint I mean gez
how many times did you need to paint
this or paint it at all but yeah this
also Builds on this scene's parallel to
Doc Brown's model of Hill Valley Town
Square and Back to the Future which he
told Marty McFly he didn't have time to
paint Loki says the figurine looks like
Mobius but it's actually Victor timley
which is a great call back because in
episode four they argued over whether it
looked more like Mobius or Loki and Loki
just has to win the argument now Loki
speedily walks through it going to take
some doing is that going to be easy lot
of temporal radiation everybody
following good yes they all respond at
the same time this kind of comedic
timing totally reminds me of another
Christopher Lloyd classic from the 80s
clue make a long story short too late
Loi asks OB how long it will take to
learn everything he knows about
mechanics physics and Engineering
decades
centuries and I love the little
pneumatic tube sound effect in the
background to underscore all this
sinking in for Loki and then o centuries
this is the most painful time Jump title
screen since 5 years later in Avengers
endgame Loki's dilemma here is inspired
of of course by Concepts like Groundhog
Day and for the movie Groundhog Day
director Harold RIS said that Bill
Murray's character Phil Connor was stuck
reliving that day for 10,000 years and
like Loki on this show Phil Connor's
reached a similar state of Nirvana I'm a
God you're God I'm a God I'm not the god
I don't think unlike Phil Loki was
already a God and as guardians of Rost
Giants age over the course of 5,000
years anyway so for Loki this is kind of
like a couple back-to-back coid
lockdowns so now super confident he
walks timely through it now it looks
lethal it is absolutely safe watch this
look your turn I'll take those thank you
thank you when you're ready ready and go
yes he's so smoothly efficient
anticipating Victor's every response
saving every second of time Mobius
starts to say better watch out OB looks
like someone's coming for your job
that's right I'm a coming I'm a coming
now this finale doesn't answer it but if
OB was the original builder of the TVA
then yeah Loki does end up coming for
his job by building his new kind of loom
he types in the password super fast and
Loki just knows the password which I'm
going to assume came from him trying
every permutation of password for
centuries until he got the right one
this time the camera swoops in the same
way on Victor that it did in episode
before but instead of the radiation
killing him it just bumps him a bit and
he keeps going Loki keeps incredibly
calm what did I tell you do not put the
multiplier down it will roll off the
gang way
that's right well done when the green
button initially doesn't work the
background behind Victor does depict
some purple colored cracks which do look
like the terorism reality in Spider-Man
no way home and the reality Rift in the
Marvels I didn't spoil it it was in the
trailer the multiplier fires into the
loom and while the music becomes
Victorious and everyone cheers
triumphantly if you look at the sacred
timeline it's not actually condensing
when Victor makes it back in he says
pumpkins I have no idea why he says
pumpkins I guess there is an old timey
phrase of some pumpkins which would
refer to someone or something impressive
but he just says pumpkins like is he
hungry do he think Miss minutes is a
pumpkin is this like another example of
him inventing words like shray but
despite their parent success the loom
begins overloading again and Victor
realizes it's a scaling problem that you
cannot scale for infinite it's
like trying to divide by zero so in
mathematics when you divide a number by
a smaller and smaller number you
approach Infinity like 10 divided by 2
is is 5 by 1 is 10 by 1/2 is 20 by 1/4
is 40 and so on and so on but we cannot
say 10 / 0 is infinity because zero has
no multiplicative inverse that would be
a number when divided by itself would
equal one because 1/ 0 * 0 is still zero
that's why it's kind of a rule in
mathematics that cannot be broken and
there's various further reasons why
mathematicians can't even like invent a
way to bypass this Loki says so no
matter how much we increase the
throughput it will never be enough
enough never enough and the loom will
always fail yeah before it was Loki who
finished everyone else's sentences but
now it's Victor finishing his Sylvie
suggests this all started with her
decision and Loki reluctantly returns to
the Citadel the events of the season 1
finale we saw Sylvie in slow motion the
same shot in that episode so it makes
for the perfect moment for Loki to slip
back to it's like when we saw it in slow
motion before the show was kind of
hinting hey we might come back to this
this time he tries for a more convincing
speech stop I've been where you are I
felt what you
feel one major difference you may notice
in the Citadel is that now the fire in
the fireplace causes the room to Glow
much brighter whereas in the season 1
finale the room was much gloomier I
think the difference reflects how Loki
is now seeing he remains true self
though not at first Sylvie says you've
been seduced by a throne the last thing
I want is a throne o in that is where he
ends up so we get another round of Loops
each one ending with Sylvie repelling
Loki and the sound of he remains gasping
and saying his final
words now the words feel kind of like a
mockery for Loki because he remains NOS
Loki is going to keep looping back on
this Loki even Loops back to the
elevator when he remains was eating an
apple not what you were expecting H
bites am man Flesh and Blood don't tell
me I'm a disappointment ah they cleverly
spliced this together with a shot from
season 1 episode 6 and then edited it on
major rubbing his nose to give us this
new angle from the side with the actors
back in the same wardrobe it's kind of
like a Back to the Future Part Two when
zamus restaged much of the events of the
dance in 1955 to shoot it at new angles
as Marty Loops back on that history
normally here after rubbing his nose he
remains anticipates Sylvie preparing to
strike him from behind and he Taps his
master tin pad to hop around the
elevator this time he doesn't even reach
for the temp pad so he must anticipate
Loki this time grabbing her arm to stop
her he knows that Loki is time slipping
and I love this little attention to
detail to prove that we now do see Loki
getting worn down and dejected until he
finally snaps that he remains to do
something and he remains freeze his time
oh come on you're not telling me you
haven't learned how to
Paul's
time
yet I figured you'd be way past that
thank you to Dr Squatch for sponsoring
this video and no Dr Squatch is not some
fictional physician it's a line of
awesome smelling soaps and yeah actually
the mascot is a fictional physician so I
got ahead of myself there let's give
these a
whip you've probably seen these all over
the Internet and have been curious about
trying them well now is the perfect time
because Dr Squatch is doing a buy three
get three bundle for new customers
meaning you would be getting three free
soaps it's a total of $28 off and rounds
out to $4 a bar which is a great deal
look I know it's impossible to show
smell via YouTube but these soaps smell
awesome again I think my favorite
are Bay Rum and
then wood barrel Bourbon rum and bourbon
you know I'm seeing a theme here but
they have a nice like earthy wooden
sweet scent and I haven't told the MS
that I've switched to using these but
she has noticed something different she
tells me to leave the room less often
it's pretty awesome you get six bars of
soaps to try especially heading into
winter because I don't want to smell
like fruit stand at a farmers market by
using all those generic brand soaps cool
fresh
Alo yeah that's the Dr Squatch
difference Dr Squatch is currently doing
a buy three get three bundle for new
customers meaning you could be getting
three free soaps it's a total of $28 off
and rounds out to $4 bar again a great
deal to level up your showers and save
some scratch on scented soaps check out
Dr squatches by three get three bundle
by clicking the link in the description
or go to drsquatch.com slne rockstars of
course as we learn later Loki does know
how to pause time his frustration in his
comment that he remains we realized
later was actually part of Loki's plan
to get her remains to intervene so that
they could talk but her remains does
know that this isn't the first time
they've had this kind of conversation I
know about the slipping and who do you
think paved that road he remains brags
that he never planned to just sit back
and let Sylvie kill him he knew that it
would lead to Loki slipping through time
putting Loki in a position to think he
could save the TVA so that Loki would
inevitably slip back here so the men
could talk he M suggested that he
include Loki into this in their first
meeting if Loki was listening carefully
I told you
reincarnation baby but come on he
remains he remains said reincarnation
baby in a very different context you
plunge your blade in my chest and an
infinite amount of me start another
multiversal war and I just end up right
back here anyways reincarnation baby
yeah before he suggested it was going to
be another Kang who would end up right
back here now he's saying he literally
this variant would have never left the
chair and Loki's need to time slip to
loop back would in effect respawn him
but then we get to the most important
Exchange in this scene Loki takes a
moment and then tells he remains as if
testing him we die with a dying we're
born with a
dead uh-huh ooh for the first time Loki
has said something that threw off he
remains I don't think he knows this
reference this is a line from TS
Elliot's poem little Gidding which is
the fourth part of TS Elliot's four
quartets the Fuller passage is we die
with a dying see they depart we go with
them we are born with the dead see they
return and bring us with them little
Gideon is a town in England and the poem
is about a narrator who meets a ghost
who's a combination of various poets and
literary figures tslot is saying that
Humanity can only avoid war by learning
the lessons of the past it says that
we're only saved by understanding the
unity of the past present and future you
can see how this applies to what Loki is
going through you can only prevent
multiversal War by learning lessons from
the past in my deep dive of Christopher
Nolan's Interstellar I pointed out that
one of the books that Nolan handpicked
for the all important bookshelf is
selected poems by TS Elliott Christopher
Nolan actually said of these poems quote
concepts of time and space at their most
complex are sometimes best expressed
through ART rather than science Elliot's
four quartets are as thought-provoking
about time as any scientific text and
the first of those four quartets is
actually TS Elliott's burnt notion which
opens with time present and time past
are both perhaps present and time future
and time future contained in time past a
theme that applies to the grandfather
Paradox that gets presented in the
tester active Interstellar but also to
the type of time travel that this season
of Loki is presenting by the way TS
Elliot having a big weekend in Marvel
Andrew Lloyd Weber's cats was based on
poems by TS Elliott old Possum's book of
practical cats and a number from that
show has a big moment in the Marvels but
by saying this Loki is testing he
remains he's reciting this poetry to
hint to he remains that he did actually
learn some lessons about the past but
Loki recites the line in a way that
sounds like they just could be an in
context morbid Overture about their Doom
status or maybe the Ragnarok cyclical
nature of death and rebirth so he
remains here's this and he's just like I
don't know where you're going with that
and since he CAU he remains off guard
Loki uses this moment to show his
[Music]
cards and what makes you
think this is the first time we've had
this this conversation only now does he
he remains drop the and take
Loki seriously how is Victor timely yes
for all the criticism Major's got for
his overthe toop performance as Victor
timely you got to appreciate him doing
an impression of himself here it's not
100% Victor timely it's like 55% Victor
timely actually now Majors completely
drops all theatricality and speaks
plainly scaling problem that's what he
told you Victor told you it was a
scaling problem wow no no there's no
there's no problem come compared to the
impishness he played he remains with in
season 1 episode 6 hopping on the desk
and whatnot this is the first time we've
seen a Kang just be chill which is
important because we really need to
trust the guy when he finally explains
the truth that the temporal Loom is a
fail safe it's only designed to preserve
the sacred timeline and it automatically
deletes branches and if the TVA at that
time gets destroyed no biggie it's easy
to rebuild so yes we were right that the
TVA has gone through several cycles of
Destruction destruction is just part of
its cyclical protocol Loki responds but
a waste of time indeed centuries but you
know what not fully wasted because those
centuries primed Loki for the important
evolutionary steps he takes this episode
he needs to be divorced from the flow of
time F main says and as you may or may
not know my variant are already out
there we'll find them there's too many I
won't stop doesn't matter never stopped
me
before I know CH yes this rapidly edited
exchange is the most heroic and Avenger
like Loki has ever sounded my theory for
Secret Wars is that the goddess stories
Loki will assemble one team of Marvel
heroes to fight against a team selected
by Kang Prime her remains tells him that
the equation results in Loki losing and
Loki says I know because he and Sylvia
had previously realized do you think
what makes a Loki a Loki is that we're
destined to lose but then Loki sees he
remains equations on the chalkboard he
says he's going to change the equation
by breaking the loom he is basically
doing what mathematicians did with
taking the square root of neg1 and
calling it I to open a whole new field
of mathematics he's doing that by
basically putting one over zero and
calling it something new and for the
first time he remains is on the
defensive in this chess match he assumed
Loki's attachments to his friends and
soie would make it impossible for him to
live without the sacred timeline that's
why he's dealing with Loki and not with
Sylvie but after centuries Loki now
feels confident that he can build a
better timeline management system than
he remains Loom is but Loki kind of
needs to get approval from his closest
friends first Mobius so he returned to
time theater number 25 with Loki back in
his prisoner jumpsuit in his collar
Mobius with a can of josta from the very
first episode remember those was also
titled glorious purpose Loki now
predicts Mobius his whole plan
interrogation routine and he gets to the
Brass tax how do you choose who lives
and who dies yeah Loki's just here to
learn from Mobius because he knows what
he's going to do Mobius tells a story a
couple Hunter went out on a mission
somewhere near the Black Sea to find a
variant who's going to be responsible
for 5,000 deaths they get there and
there's a little hiccup the variant is
an 8-year-old boy so the Black Sea is in
Eastern Europe surrounded by Bulgaria
Georgia Romania Russia turkey and
Ukraine could this future murderous boy
have grown up to be Victor Von Doom
larious precise location in Eastern
Europe has shifted around in Marvel
Comics and it's usually around Serbia or
Romania so it could be but I don't know
Victor isn't really known for having a
brother Mobius says that the hunter
hesitated but a couple Hunters died and
his partner had to step in and prune the
kid we learned that partner was Ren
Slayer remember she did something
similar with young Sylvie and that would
mean that Mobius was the hunter who
hesitated why did he hesitate at the
sight of Two Brothers playing in the
water well maybe because somewhere deep
down he thought about his sons in a jet
ski day Mobius breaks down the weight of
I am burdened with glorious purpose most
purpose is more burden than Glory what
an amazing deconstruction of a lion that
has echoed through the MCU for over 10
years Loki shakes Mobius his hand to
thank him for explaining how to live
with the burden of being a constant
timeline Monitor and mobus in the room
spaghettify and it's just beautiful but
in contrast with a painful version of
that spaghettification is we return to
episode 5 Bri wind Mobius split into
strands and Loki pauses this so that he
can talk to Sylvie what's
happening we're outside time the sound
design here is just really cool it kind
of sounds like a Rushing River that
we're submerging into Sylvie deduc is
that Loki would have to kill her to save
the sacred timeline but she reminds him
that the sacred timeline sucks and he
shouldn't want to to take away free will
if it's to protect that she goes on I
grew up in Apocalypse as Loki I've lived
through enough of them to know that
sometimes it's okay to destroy something
but then Loki who has been finishing
sentences throughout this episode
realizes there is more to this sentence
if
if there's a hope that you can replace
that
thing with something better I love this
line and I love that it's coming up in
this series analog of a writer's room
with all of AD Doug's Post-it notes on
that board for the story beats this line
from Loki is a difficult Choice every
writer of fiction has had to face
sometimes you have to as they call it
Kill Your Darlings to toss out an entire
storyline or a character or a concept
that you work so hard on but you do it
with the hope that if you came up with
that thing you can also come up with
something better writers just have to
know that it's not the thing you created
that you have the faith in it's the
Creator that still exists inside
yourself that was always is able to make
something new Eric Martin actually said
in an interview that there was
originally an entirely different concept
that they wrote for episode 5 that that
was their favorite episode of the season
but the Marvel Studios Brain Trust nuked
it because it never would have worked
and Eric Martin agreed with that
decision but he had to spend a whole
weekend writing a new script for episode
5 and we ended up getting one hell of an
episode and we're going to dig into what
that mystery nuked episode was in the
sneak peek on Sunday leing and silie
Loki inhales like he's taking a plunge
and we are back in the loom room right
after Victor stuck his head in the head
scan this time Loki concedes to Mobius
that the figurine wasn't Mobius it was
Loki and he makes the walk himself and
he locks Sylvia and Mobius out telling
them I know what I
want I know what kind of God I need to
be for
you for all of us so first off I love
how they framed Sylvie and Mobius in the
same window so this way Loki could say
it to both of them but this line Echoes
the very first Thor film right before
Loki dropped off the bifrost bridge I
could have done it father I could have
done it for
you for all of
us no Loki back then Loki wasn't being
honest he was just doing it for himself
but this time he truly is taking on this
burden for those he loves Loki marches
down the gang way his clothes tear away
into a new Godly form a green cloak and
a dramatic crown with tall horns the
crown is actually made of the same kugi
cracked pattern that he remains Citadel
was made out out of as Loki destroys the
loom his face seems to grow older a
little bit it kind of looks like that of
Richard E Grant as classic Loki when in
season 1 episode 5 he shouted this
episode's
title Papa remember when sylv's record
store spaghettified last episode she
briefly found herself in a dark green
void with these dead dark green Vines
and that's where Loki finds himself now
but he realizes by grabbing these dead
branches and by not letting them go he
can bring life into them and by doing
that he creates an opening to The
Citadel bedrock when he steps off the
broken gang way reminding us again of
the broken bifrost bridge that he
dropped from in Thor now like Indiana
Jones taking a leap of faith onto the
invisible bridge in the Last Crusade
there is now a path for Loki to walk on
it's a journey into mystery now I have
talked about this season how normally in
the MCU when there is a huge effects
sequence where we're often looking at a
big wash of glowing energy that doesn't
seem to have any weight or Texture but
in Loki with the loom every shot of it
has been awe inducing because we know
what it is this sequence takes that a
step further without any words or any
real logical Baseline to understand what
the hell is happening here we just
follow the emotion and we go with it and
we get it all we know is that Loki has
transformed and he kind of looks like a
beetle crawling through some dark
Tangled dead roots of a tree that he's
wearing some Swanky slippers in that he
cannot he will not let go because he is
determined to build something new I
don't think we've ever seen visual
storytelling this impressionistic in the
MCU before and production designer KRA
farani along with Natalie Holt Eric
Martin Justin binon and Aaron Morehead
all of them deserve awards for this
whereas he remains created his sacred
timeline by using elith to violently
devour branches he didn't like Loki does
the work and he does it by hand he
strains to grab every single Vine no
matter how heavy or how strong that
tensile strength is because he doesn't
want any branch to die and he heaves it
along his upward climb we're reminded of
Peter Parker holding his arms out in a
Christ pose trying to keep the two
halves of the Theory together or his
variant Toby McGuire Peter Parker trying
to keep the train from crashing we feel
the weight The Strain on his arms and
actually speaking of Christ poses with
Loki's Barbed Crown doesn't he kind of
seem like Jesus carrying his cross up
the hill on a path to be crucified to
die for our sins to open the gates of
Heaven I don't know if I were to tell
Loki this Christian mythology he'd be
like hey I'm Loki the god of stories
from Asgard but notice how the gold and
all the kugi cracks of that asteroid
blow upward with him forming a path for
him to follow a yellow brick road you
might say those cracks were not there to
show how the timeline was destined to be
broken they were there because it was
broken without the rightful God there to
unify everything and now that he's here
the gold flows into a chair to form a
throne for him but it's not a beautiful
Odin style well perfectly molded Throne
it's just kind of a Stumpy throne with
grooves on the back why to make it easy
for the vines to jut upward behind him
we see all this while the architecture
of heade Citadel crumbles away Loki
illuminates all of the vines becoming
his own handheld loom in the heart of
the timeline and as the camera pulls
back it rotates 90° and it gives us This
Magnificent shot a perfect depiction of
the eril worlds tree from Asgardian in
Norse mythology The Roots below are dead
but being woven by Loki and the trunk
into life and above they blossom into
the blue and purple ends that used to be
part of the broken Multiverse they
remain though now looking like promising
fruit the fruit of his labor Loki is
finally a god of stories with a glorious
purpose or really a glorious burden he's
committed himself to an eternity of
solitude remember Agent Coulson once
told him that he lacked conviction but
he has found that conviction he replaced
he remains automated Loom with an
organic living Garden that he actively
tills rather than pruny branches he
strains to weave every Vine in he has
shown that a Multiverse can live in
harmony and that Multiverse is alive it
can grow adapt change die and reproduce
so on screen we see after period which
is just hilarious who knows what that
means we see a new poster in the TVA
let's grow together nurture our nature
for a stable future with the depiction
of the errill tree with workers growing
it instead of pruning branches like in
the past TVA propaganda posters now
nature and nurture are commonly seen as
opposites but here they are used in the
same sentence you'll see on the Chron
monitor screen the timeline has now been
reoriented 90° so it's not lateral
anymore but growing upward and there is
room for plenty of branches in addition
to analysts and Hunters there is a new
position in the TVA Workforce workers in
these kind of white clothes with these
white hats they kind of look like
medical workers or maybe botanists of
some kind I just assume that they're in
charge of the health of a given Branch
may be tasked with finding ways to help
it grow sustainably OB reboots Miss
minutes she appears from her original
orange binary look to her cartoon self
they still don't know if that she's
going to kill them all mobus hands B15 a
case vile reports on the variance of he
remains do any of them know that we
exist yet nope I guess one of them
caused a little bit of a ruckus on
616 adjacent realm but they handled it
so we're all good for now oh baby 616
adjacent realm is referring to the
quantum realm of universe 616 and this
Ruckus was Kang the Conqueror in the
events of Ant-Man the was quantum Mania
by saying they handled it he's referring
to Ant-Man wasp Cassie Lang Hank Pim and
Janet vany actually those photos in the
file show Kang the Conqueror holding out
his two fists to blast the Freedom
Fighters when he floated down on that
disc from his Penthouse and then the
other photo I think that's Kang's time
chair or the ruins of it now the risk
report form with all the text is kind of
hard to make out but at the top is a
variant number and then a name and then
a location and then by temporal Aura
beside that I think we see the word Kang
in quotes and then beneath that powers
and then related case files with a bunch
of other numbers listed I think these
might be referencing some of the other
kangs the quantum Mania mid- credit
scene the printed text shows something
about apprehended for the energy surge I
don't know folks I'm going to keep
trying to make out what this says and if
anything big comes out of it I'm going
to make a follow-up video but the case
File that mobus request shows that he is
labeled variant number M
ff353 M for Mobius just like Loki's
variant number is l1130 but ff353 is a
reference to Fantastic 4 353 from the
year 1991 this was the issue in which
Mobius IM Mobius was first introduced as
that name Mobius tells B15 to leave the
past murals up both the Kang era and the
timekeeper era saying that those who
forget the past are doomed to you know
which is really the theme TS Elliot was
getting at in that poem the war room is
now filled with all ranks of the TV
Hunters analysts Engineers so there is
now another engineer beside OB we see
some judges with their sashes we see
health workers we see judge gamble as
well as that sleepy judge from episode 1
and I think that is the librarian from
season 1 episode 2 OB unboxes a TVA
handbook second edition crediting both
Ora Boris and Victor timley we see young
Victor timley back in 1868 Chicago
continuing to pour wax candles and he
turns around to look at the open window
but nothing comes through it this time
so the kid gets to live a good life
hopefully as a candlemaker to bring some
light into the world Ren Slayer wakes up
in the void behind her are the pyramids
and the Spinx that we saw in the void in
season 1 episode 5 remember we're pretty
sure that Spinx as Jonathan Major's nose
and face under the grass is the same
golden floor emblem that Mobius had just
brushed his shoe across showing the TVA
emblem and for all time always it is
stained with bluish marks maybe it's
some kind of oxidation either way I
think the implication here is that the
void was one of the past errors of the
TVA that he remains allowed to be
destroyed when the loom got overloaded
and he used that Rubble as elith
speeding ground we see purple light
flashing on Ren slayer's face meaning
elith is approaching and ren Slayer just
stares it down not flinching look folks
I have a hard time accepting this as the
end of RN Slayer if it is I just think
her Arc the season was really
underdeveloped like I still think heri
Ms must have needed her in order to tame
elith to begin with and the framing here
just reminds me of the moment John lock
on Lost stared down the smoke monster
which is really the beginning of his
story but we have to to acknowledge that
Eric Martin did tell Cinema Blend quote
we approached this as like two halves of
a book season 1 first half season 2 we
Clos the book on Loki in the TVA so if
we don't get a season 3 I'm okay with
that but I would love to see RN Slayer
holding the Reigns of elith and some
Marvel title in the future movius
watches as his nonvariant self plays
with the kids the inmates are running
the Asylum okay okay PE with the TVA
under its own control the former
prisoners are running the Asylum Sylvie
says it's weird the is's not here isn't
it yeah yeah but he is there because
notice how the lens flare causes this
Frame to be filled with green and golden
Hues Mobius says he's just going to wait
here for a little bit let time pass I
love it Mobius has been in the TVA for
eons outside of time just kind of
treading water in time and now he's
going to let it actually pass and let
that current take him wherever it goes
but you know he's got his eye on that
red skoo poking out of the garage it's
calling his name but Mobius is words of
let time pass Echo go through Loki's
timeline tree each Vine you'll notice is
filled with different strands of colors
each representing a whole different
Universe all allowed to coexist in
harmony God of stories Loki absolutely
heard the words let time pass and that
is what he is doing his greatest fear
that he told Sil about last episode was
being alone but he has overcome that
fear by realizing he was afraid of
something else that his friends might
not have the chance to be alive and to
be free for someone who has lived
centuries of Life what could be a more
glorious purpose than that the final
casting director photos shows Sylvie
from the train in season 1 episode 3 B15
from season 1 episode 2 Casey from the
checkin desk from the very first episode
OB from the first episode of this season
Mobius from the very first episode and
Loki after he sat up in the desert back
in the very first scene of the series
this show has just meant so much to me
to be able to nerd out with all of you
every week has been such a privilege and
I promise I don't take that for granted
so thank you thank you for supporting
new rock stars I love you guys and we
still more videos we want to make about
Loki so please subscribe to new
rockstars and to all the channels in the
new Rockstar Network to see me face
public humiliation for my silly silly
theories about McDonald's Jack or the
TVA toilet green pie what was I thinking
join us for our live show in Los Angeles
on November 16 follow me at eaos thanks
to Noah Chen for helping me research
this breakdown thanks for watching and
I'll see you next time
bye